I think if you could be yourself in all
that it is what typically happens is
people like you show me somebody who
could take a hit I'll show you a good
entrepreneur because you know what I
found I found deaths face was just like
closet space and never stays empty for
long they told me about they're gonna
have an amusement park one day a Tom +
Chee amusement part like ok they're
definitely on dope what I've learned to
get myself through business and build my
business a is a new tape and it goes
like this you all I wanted to do was get
a whole over to let her know we'd figure
something out in the world but I knew
we'd figure something out don't worry
that competitive spirit drives you
through all the things that don't make
any common sense in life when you're
young you're too stupid to know any
better you've never jumped off a cliff
and fallen flat on your face if you
could work as a free slave even for a
license top salesperson just sitting
next to them being their slave a servant
you're gonna learn everything the most
underestimated tool used in business
today is the fun part she's an American
businesswoman investor author and
television personality she's one of the
investors on ABC's hit show shark tank
she has an estimated net worth of 80
million dollars she's Barbara Corcoran
and hear her top ten rules for success
the upside when you're getting much
older and I've gotten strong and
stronger in this way as I buy the Year
by the minute okay and I wish I knew it
earlier it's to be yourself because
people even if you weird a weirdo is
often the most loved person in a team I
think if you could be yourself in all
that it is what typically happens is
people like you because they can sense
it's a real deal it's the airs the phone
enos of trying to impress the
insecurities all the stuff that we all
strive so hard for when we're young that
gets in the way you know there was
actually a two-year period where I had
my hair poofed up and didn't wash it all
week to try to fit in with the society
ladies you know but my scalp itch like
crazy I had to get rid of that haircut
you know that pool thing once a week
hello
Hey yeah and the only time my business
ever fell behind was when I was so busy
watching my competition I analyzed
everything I had the listings on a chart
by category by size who had one who was
my dog but the thought I was like a
genius at my field it was the only year
of my whole career I never pushed the
business ahead I was so busy watching
the next guy wasn't watching me all
right so being itself I would say would
be the most important thing let me tell
you rejection is the big kahuna in all
entrepreneurship okay show me somebody
who could take a hit I'll show you a
good entrepreneur I hope I made that up
I think
it's all and how well you get back up
and you know what I have fun by the way
because if you think about a great
salespeople a couple million dollars a
year
someone apartments in York City which my
great salespeople do all great
entrepreneurs all business comes from
them and manage your own business they
hire staff they're entrepreneurs and you
know what I found is the only difference
between the superstars making the loans
a year the person's barely getting by
the only difference not contacts not how
hard they work some people work just as
hard don't make any money right it's how
long they feel sorry for themselves once
they get hit some people could take a
hit and look at the two weeks they're at
their desks they look like they're
working but then I'll work you're
mentally they're out there the great
salespeople will take the hit and then
they jump right back up as though
they've been hurt just as much as the
next guy but they work right through and
keep going let me tell you if you have
that skill if you should be an
entrepreneur because you will be paying
well for it the single best thing I do
more than anything else I can do
building businesses for myself and other
people was just speaking for myself is I
fail well I fall on my face let me tell
you nobody is better at pretending I'm
not thinking of a quick cover-up trying
to keep moving and you want to know in
that act itself of getting back up fast
you always stumble onto something good
and you want to know one other things
this is I'm not a religious person cuz I
was raised so god damn religious I don't
want ever think about it again but I do
believe once you put your mind and going
forward on anything it is almost like a
battle cry that goes out in the universe
and the world rallies around you
just comes to you for again and again so
to have that kind of good faith that I'm
just getting back up here if I'm gonna
get slammed life is fair in his own
weird way in that way in building
businesses you will be swept up by some
lucky chance it happened to me every
time I got back up it's been before
you're ready my mom always said is never
a good time to have a baby and she had
Ted I don't ever remember her not being
pregnant she's always pregnant my memory
pregnant she's always pregnant right I
practice the same philosophy with
building my business I found it was
never really good time to expand but I
always expanded and the thing that I
practice religiously that helped me grow
my business because you have to realize
if you're the little guy you got the big
guy up here you can't do the same you've
got to do like five times more to catch
up so I practice if I had a sales
organization of twenty five people and I
thought you know what I'm going to hire
an office I could hold 50 I'm gonna
double the size I never hired the office
of what rented the office that needed 50
I went out and killed myself to get an
office that held 100 I doubled my
expectation because you know what I
found I found deaths face was just like
closet space never stays empty for long
you get all those desks waiting for
bodies you're a whole focuses I'm
finally salespeople we all focus on
shrinking them fast and better to get
them productive and I found that I was
able to leapfrog over my competitors
because I was super aggressive and
expanding before I was ready and I
trusted that somehow it would all work
out and always didn't work out so you
have a gun to your on him you have to
run like crazy to catch up to yourself
and so it took a little courage or
stupidity on the front side but without
it I could have never grown and become
the number one firm I knew it just
wouldn't have happened it was too long
and catching up everybody was in
business much too long for me to ever
catch up so that lesson is expand before
you're ready when I met Tom + Chee they
were had just come out of selling their
grilled cheese on donuts out of a tent
in Cincinnati all right what was so
interesting about them however they
weren't talking about it Tim they were
talking about a franchise of hundreds of
franchise so on she's on doughnuts okay
right what do you think happened they
told me about they're gonna have an
amusement park one day atomic G
amusement park
like okay they're definitely on dope
these people alright but I don't think
so anymore I can't wait to go to music
park they have 171 franchises across
America exactly what they envisioned
they got exactly the picture in great
detail where they're going to do it how
they're going to go to the other side of
the river and Cincinnati which is
another state I forget which one it is
how they're going to come across back
buh-buh-buh-buh
I'm like okay well guess what I should
have believed them okay
they have big pictures in their head and
every entrepreneur might not have a
business plan with everything in fact
none of them really do I think the
grossly overrated but they sure have a
movie in the head of who they're going
to be when they grow up alright and when
they can't express that movie on Shark
Tank I'm always at Viking if they don't
see it how am I going to see it and
believe it and they're not going to get
there if I even walk into like a
cocktail party or something and I meet
someone and then it's like it they'll
into each other and they go nice to meet
you and they turn away that little
quarter-turn I'm embarrassed to admit it
I'm like dying it's like oh [ __ ] they
don't like me oh my god you know this
isn't my crowd anyway I shouldn't have
come but what I've learned to get myself
through business and build my business a
is a new tape and it goes like this cue
I have just as much right to be here as
you I'm just as smart as you are you
might not think of smart but I know I'm
smart guess what I've done a lot don't
you dear looking down on me what I'd do
this whole thing on myself and you know
what it gets me to do it gets me to step
forward one more time and get just a
little bit more confidence for that
circumstance but I'm so grateful that
I've had to come out of that hole to do
it carry Chang had I would say 90% of
the business coming out of Taiwan
because she spoke Taiwanese and she sold
condominiums and then one day I'm
watching the news early and I see the
Taiwanese stock market is this such a
thing some big Taiwanese then crashed
I'm sitting there like oh my god Kerry
is gonna be over here she was producing
single-handedly I must have had maybe
150 salespeople at the time she was
single-handedly producing 80 percent of
my income this is important all my eggs
were in the carry basket I immediately
called Kerry up on her first cell phone
her second cell phone her home her
office for Chinese cousins I cannot
reach her next day I can't reaches she's
disappeared I know Kerry has committed
Harry Caray all I wanted to do was get a
hold of her to let her know we'd figure
something out in the work but I knew
we'd figure something out don't worry
she firing marches into my office as she
always does like she owns it she's
always insulted me a little but what the
heck she'd make the money I'll settle
marches into my office I got Kerry I
wanted to say you're alive I thought she
was dead she does about what I do no
Karen would you do said I have for
tonight I put everyone
customers I think you guys said I got
132 listings
what I have to say the poetry in motion
in sales can counter him she let a hand
roll her foot or a brash hair or
whatever those things ago she saw the
opportunity and what do you think Kerry
did she hired two Japanese speaking
assistance within I'd say a week and a
half how does she find them all right
because the Japanese market was booming
and she had them as the interlayer she
showed apartments to the Japanese and
let me tell you I found out in that
chapter the Japanese really don't like
the Chinese and they loved buying a
Chinese apartments at a steep discount
and Carrie like Dumbledore visits no one
sells more property the Japanese today
than Carrie GI no one salesmen were
Chinese and if anything happens to those
marks I'm sure she'll go to school learn
how to speak German or Russian or
whatever the heck she has to learn that
I do a wonderful example of someone who
takes a hit competitive if I tell Jim
from cousins Maine lobster I have his
picture here but you know I talked about
him before if I tell him one little
thing about the guy he used to compete
with on the hockey team Jim was a semi
professional hockey player had some
injury or something in the minor leagues
if I'm telling that right but anyway his
archenemy on the other team was a guy
named Luke what do you think happened
Luke's for me Jim's from Maine Luke went
into the lobster business all I have to
do to double sales say hey Jay here Luke
open another restaurant talk about
competitive spirit he's ready to kill he
doesn't stop working he hates the idea
that somebody might beat him at a game
it says DNA and his partner savings the
same way all I have to do is tell Grace
& Lace who makes beautiful lacy socks
and shawls in my most successful
business by far in terms of making money
and what do I have to do to get them
going hardly anything all I have to do
is I got a big check from a cousin's
today do not get a check from her like
within the week a bigger check they're
winning we're more successful why I
didn't compete with Milan that's the way
they weren't competitive you get an
entrepreneur who doesn't feel the heat
of competition he's not going to be good
on his feet she's not going to come to
the fore when she really needs it
that competitive spirit drives you
through all the things that don't make
any common sense in life that's what it
does the best time to start your own
business is as quick as you can and I'm
going to give you two reasons why when
you're young you're too stupid to know
any better you've never jumped off a
cliff and fallen flat on your face so
you have courage once life gets a hold
of you you learn exactly what to be
afraid of what you might not succeed at
everything gets nipped in so I think the
best time to start a business quite
frankly is while you're in college what
do you have in college why is that the
perfect time you're open to the universe
you have a tremendous support system of
professors with all different
backgrounds ready to help you and you
have colleagues with different strengths
around you the fellow students and
you're hungry you're hungry to prove
something so in short the best time is
the earliest time you can possibly do
before you have the wife the kids the
husband in the mortgage and the most
fertile time is right when you're in
school even before you get out that's
what I believe so my boyfriend is trying
to break into the real estate industry
in New York and he's finding it a little
bit challenging so I just want to know
what advice you would have for somebody
who's trying to start off yeah well the
first thing you should do is go and work
for a top salesperson best way to go in
the easiest job to get in New York if
you want to go in real estate is to go
to rental company it's like the bottom
feeders right there it's terrible but
you know what's great about and I ran a
rental company for seven years before I
went eight years before I went into
sales thank God and you know what's
great about it you get a hundred times
at bat in other words you answered 50
calls
what is that apartment available that
apartment available different when
you're selling it's a slow motion so you
get a lot of practicing if you could
work as a free slave even for a licensed
top salesperson just sitting next to
them being their slave a servant you're
going to learn everything you can't
learn in a real estate school you got to
be on the street and learn it and so
that's the most important thing fun is
good for business back to my dad I
mimicked my father's bizarreness and it
gave me a company culture that no one
could compete with at first my
competitors
made fun of us they call us the court
cats they say we like a Midwestern firm
which isn't a compliment in New York
City is supposed to be sophisticated and
so how did I use fun to build my
business easy
the first uninvent i plan we were like
seven or eight people I think we have a
picture of it here if you want to go
back maybe one slide you'll see it oh
we're already onto something else
all right we got exciting slides today
all over the place okay but anyway I'll
paint the picture with my words I've
told everyone to dress in your best
outfit the absolute best outfit really
decked yourself up and wear your best
jewelry do you make up fresh like four
o'clock in the afternoon not just wear
it from the morning we're going
somewhere special I gave him the
invitation two weeks early people talked
about it for two weeks excitement and
looking forward to something that's half
the joy of anything fun as you know
that's at that what do you wear when you
wear it they came down to the street a
Madison success Street where our office
was and I had an old clunky
double-decker bus waiting for them
looked like it's cheap and retired a
hundred years ago I said come on up come
on up they sat on the top this was open
air and then I took those fancy ladies
and one one of my salespeople gay guy
who dressed better than all of us we
couldn't compete we took those fancy
ladies right up
tarah I'm on a slow to Harlem and Harlem
had to be the scariest place in the
universe and totally different now they
were groping the jewelry they didn't say
a word I never saw fancy ladies under
pressure they're no good they were
talented
I had thank God at the time only one
black salesperson V Wilson with the
biggest soul in the world and I queued
hurry not where we go she is my my
companion here we get up 245th Street in
Amsterdam Avenue and the bus driver
leaves says the engines broken we plan
that they leave us for 10 minutes in the
middle of the summer people were nuts do
V Wilson I mean we cannot talk about
this without crying and laughter all
over like it was yesterday
okay how many years ago was it V Wilson
describes that she said when the bus
driver left the bus she said I swear I
was a Ming Wei when she said maypole I
can swim there maples the kids danced
around she said whatever it's a flagpole
but that's not [ __ ] I swear I was a
maple flagpole with eight white women
Clinton here's what happened we go back
to the office
you couldn't they weren't even talking
to customers the next day nobody could
talk about anything but the trip to
Harlem they were laughing sharing what
they were thinking about the fact that
the thought that the table and I looked
at my eight salespeople and I thought to
myself wow what a team they had been in
trouble together they laughed together
they're reflecting together and for the
first time I realized I had a culture
goal and so I became the queen of fun
for the rest of my life I probably spent
as much time planning the details of
ridiculous fun frequently as much as I
did with any other part of the business
because I saw it as a power tool and
guess what I surprisingly got out of it
that I never expected I became the
creative the creative like hot ed
company in New York all the creative
ideas came out of our accountant we
tried everything first why did that
happen because we thought of all the
ideas when we having fun I never had a
good idea of my desk I thought I did but
the really winning ideas always came on
the way back from the movie theater when
we were having a management meeting I
made everybody sit under the table and
said it's about their chairs just to
move it around anything that was bizarre
get up on an elephant when people are
living in that Ian laughing they were
you know what we should really do we
should ever come up people are free
we're all equal we're all planets and I
created a powerful team as a result of
fun the most underestimated tool used in
business today is the fun card in my
opinion nobody really has fun people's
idea of fun is having a
a Happy New Year a fancy place it's fun
people do a million things like that
I had my February parties and what
happened my February parties you weren't
allowed in unless you dressed for it
dress 1940s okay how do they dress and
figure it out they look forward to it
they couldn't get it unless certain
anything would dress in pink oh my god
dress in pink right cross dress the very
last party do you know how exciting it
was to be at the Waldorf Astoria going
after my straight men swore they would
not come when I come and this is it
you've gone too far out I'm not
cross-dressing I knew that we're going
to crossdress
they want on this Safari they were the
best parties in town but do you know how
thrilling it was for me to be at the
Waldorf Astoria the Grand Ballroom all
that fancy this and see all these people
I couldn't recognize that you Harry it's
me it's me under here it was bizarre but
you want to know what happened they
would go out and show the listings of
the other brokers say you know we were
less than know what happen at your party
I could have sold every ticket to my
competitors for that party for a
thousand a piece if I could if I would
have you know everybody had read our
parties because they were bizarre okay
and on and on and on I think I told you
and by the way you know it's great and
still true today in New York I imagined
streaming Dallas or wherever your firm
do you know that the venues in New York
are at half-price in February because
it's the worst month for parties so you
get half-price okay tax fine the most
depressed sales month of the year in
every business February I don't know why
it is but it is and lifts everybody up
and you get everything at half-price
okay fun is good for business
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Victoria fo asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave me in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of Barbara's
top 10 rules hit you the hardest is
going to have the biggest impact on your
business and your life leave it in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
but I was dumping the pasta what a night
into the sink and all of a sudden Ramone
Simone walks in and he says you know
Barbara we have something serious to
discuss I'm going to marry a secretary
what Tina
she went from Tina the wonderful
secretary I won't even put a label on
her okay I just couldn't believe my ears
or my eyes like what how's that possible
he said take me time moving out I took
about a minute grabbed a toothbrush and
walked out the door moved in with my
girlfriend Cathy who was Lamantia 79th
Street with studio and she let me stay
there till I got my feet back under me I
should say that for the first time my
life I don't know what hit me I guess
that hit me but I can't believe I
managed it so bad I felt like I was in
nobody I went from us somebody with a
successful business for nobody because I
was turned out for a younger woman
Tina was five years younger than me I
had to admit she's prettier she had real
blond hair I was already highlighting I
hated her for that she was calm and
pretty I hated her
but I went to work every day I wanted a
fire Tina but Ray reminded me he was a
controlling partner I couldn't do that
Tina moved into my desk in Ray's office
where I used to sit and I set out with
the salespeople and every day I went in
smiling like a puppet but in my heart I
was running around a broken heart and
loss of confidence I just thought to
myself my god I was nothing before ray
found he picked me out family he was my
mentor he gave me confidence he gave me
when you start the business everything
good that had changed my life all led to
one place which was her loans along and
I thought he's right I'll never succeed
with that but I can't even remember what
clicked in my head maybe desperation
though one day I just decided I'm not
gonna do this anymore and I walked in
and I said to Ramone Simone you know
what I'm ending this business and here's
how we're going to do we're going to
chop up the 14 sales people like a
football draw you could pick the first
person I'll pick the second we'll do it
fair if you want to move out you can
move out if you want me to move out no
problem you want to keep the phone
number no problem or I'll get a new
phone number whatever you go first
he picked Norman Hirsch our star sales
person I picked Esther Kaplan I'm not so
star sales person but I had a plan for
her and we went right down the line and
I would say within maybe six minutes we
ended a partnership boom like that we
had $37,000 in cash he wrote me a check
for half the $37,000 and as luck would
have it it was a real estate recession
we're just about to dive into and why
was it great because commercial space
wasn't leasing well he was on the eighth
floor where my old office was I rented
the identical space on the 11th floor
above him there's a little ego in that
I'm sorry to say
it was I and by Monday this was on a
Thursday by Monday I move my salespeople
links and those times you could rent
black desks rent phones banker in the
operation and my seven salespeople moved
in and that was the birth of the
corporate group right before I left
Ramon Simone's office that day or I
should say ray and Tina's office that
day and by the way you know what his
real name was wasn't even Ramon simple I
fired from his mother Vicky his real
name was Ray Simon and he wasn't from
the best country like he always told me
he was from 145th Street Harlem go
figure already well anyway so right
before I left the office that's when ray
gave me the gift of a lifetime when he
said to the me those words that
reflected in my head for the rest of my
life it still gets me going you'll never
succeed without me
I'm telling you I don't believe in
negative motivation well positive person
like my mother but he really knew my
number if he had said I know you're
going to be amazing I'm sure I would
have stayed in business and the tough
times but it was that scolding tattoo in
my heart you'll never succeed without me
that every time I was near death growing
my business through the ups and downs of
the real estate recession me
overextended being over leveraged only
money la blah blah that same phrase got
me going again
he gave me an insurance policy for
success by insulting me thank God he did
I have thanked him a million times what
happened Ramone Simone you married Tina
they have three kids together they are
so much more happy to marry than myself
and my husband Bill they were meant to
be together
they were destined okay but still thank
God he gave me that insult to assure my
success for the rest of my life every
great entrepreneur is a Salesman you
can't start a business if you can't sell
your product or service and so if it's
not your nature to convince somebody to
come around to your way of thinking
you're not ever going to get your
business off the ground perception
creates reality she heard that before
or another version of the more simple
version fake it till you make it right
my mom when we were raised was very
Catholic and she only said remember the
meek will inherit the earth no need to
brag just be a great person people will
recognize it and you'll always do well
that was my mom's philosophy but she had
never been to work let me tell you New
York the nice people got mowed over I
saw that the first week I moved in right
so my mother's philosophy didn't work in
the business world may have been great
for the home but it didn't work in the
business world you know when I witness
right away that the big mouth with less
talent inherited the earth right and so
I hadn't developed for myself a really
big mouth
right and I did it very easily by
creating a rapport and I should say my
first perception lesson I learned when I
got my first $340 rental check I ran
over to Bergdorf Goodman's and blew it I
only had $1,000 I spent 340 of a
thousand you know I blew the whole money
on a fanciest coat I could find
I bought the fanciest rat hair collar
cuffs buttons fancy but you know what I
wore that coat for four years I felt
like the queen of New York real estate
cover up my bad clothes I just stormed
it around town and you want to know
something people responded differently
to me than when I had my other coat that
was from a jersey they treated me
differently and I saw the difference so
I learned to really create the image of
success or that I had it or not I was
sitting around my salespeople were
coming into my office it was another
real estate another real estate
recession they were complaining
out me not advertising for them how can
we sell if you don't advertise well I
have no money that's how I don't
advertise we're out of money
you know we're lucky to have the rent 9
and then and I thought if one more sales
person came into my office and complain
I was going to run away get it illegal
gun and kill him it's really how I felt
I had had it all right and so in
desperation they okay how do I get
people to notice us I thought oh I know
what I'll do
I took my 11 sales for the year I
divided by eleven thank God I was good
at my eleven times table the only one
came up with an average price based on
the eleven sales we had for the year and
I typed on mice electric typewriter the
Corcoran report an analysis of
Statistics and blah blah was so long I
don't remember what it was but anyway
and I put average New York City
apartment price fifty four thousand six
hundred whatever it was at the moment
and I folded them and mail them out to
every reporter that wrote for the New
York Times that day no cover no just a
simple one-page report one statistic
named after me never got a call a big
deal it took me a couple of hours that's
all it took hand address the envelopes
two weeks heads from at home on a Sunday
open up the New York Times the front
page of the real estate section which
was read by everyone the headline was
New York City house no houses price no
New York City prices hit all-time low I
read the first line it was a Catholic
miracle according to Barbara Corcoran
president of the corporate hoop what
I cut that out I went into the office
that Monday the world had changed I'm
telling you it was a bellwether changed
for my business I saw my salespeople
hustling on the phone trying to get
listings you usually called on owner
heads it's my heavier this thing there's
no MLS can I have your listing I heard
it day in and day out oh let me spell it
for you cor cor I always heard my name
spells the difficult things repeated
itself and that was the first day I
heard John Beck been my German salesman
sitting angle oh you've heard of us
cooperator you've heard it everybody
stopped he didn't have to sell the name
Mike that's weird you know in people's
minds we went from a nobody to a
somebody in one day in the life of New
York City and I said whoa I get it
I have a partner and it's called the New
York Times and so I turned out the
reports if you could advance the slide a
little bit I turned out the report got a
new red suit that became my logo you
just saw it there quickly
all right and I became the statistician
of numbers in New York I turned out a
report on anything I could think of I
churned out a Madonna report because I
read in the post that Madonna was
looking for an apartment she was
pregnant like we don't have her but I'll
write about her I put out a Madonna
report what would my Donna be looking
for top security she was a lady gaga boy
had a security a doorman building of
course you know she needed the
protection views of course anybody with
oodles of money wants two views I just
took the usual laundry dream list that
everybody wants when you got money I was
on four different television stations in
one week why because when Madonna was in
the news and the media was willing to
gobble up anything that they could get
their hands on because Madonna was in
the news and I just happen to provide it
all right do you know no one asked me if
I was working with Madonna
the last guy who introduced me on eleven
o'clock news that stuffy guy that was
fired a few years back I forget why some
conflict very stuffy very revered he
actually introduced me without moving
his lower lip at all
Barbara Corcoran celebrity broker -
little did I get rid onon Oh wouldn't
that have been nice actually she never
moves she only moved two years ago to a
double townhouse but that's so many
years later she never moved of course
but who I did get is a call from an
agent or an attorney I reaction on who
he was the very next day I was on that
last news channel and he said you seem
to be very comfortable working with
celebrities I wonder if you consider
helping my celebrity find a home okay
Richard Gere who would you rather have
Madonna or Richard Gere that's me I just
put my head in her shoes
what did he buy sadly not something
expensive a one-bedroom that he ripped
the wall down and converted to a temple
he was in his temple phase little weird
guy all right we sorry sold it apartment
like only three or four years down under
why I held it but what was great how did
it happen that I got Richard Gere and
then when we got Richard Gere poor
Richard Gere the minute he bought
something I do the Richard Gere report
leaked it to the press Richard yeah
what's he doing it's a tap up don't tell
anybody he's making a temple juicy went
on and on and on Richard Gere got me
other people they got me other people
they got me other people so what came
first the chicken or the egg certainly I
created the perception and the reality
followed and I found I did that my
entire life with anything I dreamt of
becoming I put it in the public I
figured a way to get in the public eye
and then you know what's great about it
you have to run like crazy to keep up
with yourself you're gonna make it
happens you'll want to get caught in a
lot right
it's like add anyway yeah and it worked
again and again and again